Alexis Bledel reveals her favorite
Gilmore Girls characters it's awful for
you to find out like this
I know
the 35 year old actress got candid on
The Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon
Monday when he asked her who besides her
own character Rory where her faves on
the show I think that um
Caesar is awesome he works at Luke's I
think he kind of runs the place like if
he has to go be with Lorelai he's like I
got it
okay yeah that's right so see that's a
secret one yeah yeah he's like yeah he's
underrated he's amazing and then Babette
Miss Patti every time they would come to
set they would like get together and
sing show tunes and leg it was such a
raucous day on set every day they were
there so I have to appreciate them and
then Kirk as well Alexis also put to
rest the rumors swirling on social media
to claim she doesn't know how to hold
things it was not what I was expecting
at all fans went crazy after the Netflix
revivals first promo shots came out I
was set up to fail there know somewhat
gosh how would you hold that I mean this
is normally sighs so this is no problem
I guess
you
[Music]